einzigartig ist der titel einer
veranstaltung in der steirischen belgier
kaserne in graz dabei versuchen
sogenannte behinderten
vertrauenspersonen auf die
alltagsprobleme von mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeitern mit beeinträchtigung im
österreichischen bundesheer aufmerksam
zu machen und verantwortungsträger für
dieses thema zu sensibilisieren
dabei handelt es sich meistens um dinge
wie barrierefreiheit ausgezählt wir
haben teilweise hohe vormittag gehört
oder wurde mir gesagt ist hauptstadt und
eine visuellen alarmanlagen wo es ein
paar aus gericht oder so es an
kleinigkeiten und dass das bewusstsein
bei den vorgesetzten gestärkt wird dass
diese kleinigkeiten die noch warten
sondern dass diese ausgewählt werden
dass ein sicheres und ein harmonisches
zusammenarbeiten funktioniert um eine
harmonische zusammenarbeit am ersten
erreichen zu können braucht es zum einen
den regelmäßigen kontakt zu den
arbeitskolleginnen
ja ich glaube das ist wirklich sehr
wichtig dass man wirklich auch hier gebe
es in kontakt mit menschen mit
behinderung hat weil sehr wenige
personen hanikel das bewusstsein dass
auch behinderte menschen mit behinderung
ihre stärken haben
das heißt es können natürlich alle davon
profitieren auch von den defiziten also
ich bin meiner gebärdensprache
serviceorientiert und ich kein denkmal
jeder hat zu einer behinderung oder
einschränkung andere fähigkeiten die man
im ausgleich sozusagen vorweist um nicht
behinderten besuchern einmal näher zu
bringen was es heißt im rollstuhl zu
sitzen konnte jeder einmal selbst
ausprobieren noch der mittlerweile
schaut drei oder vier offiziere soweit
braucht ob das für ihre einschätzung
das ist bei bild und leitershofen wird
dass so jemand einerseits und das mal
ausprobiert und so war es dann auch es
ist wirklich an große herausforderung
die bewunderte an jeden der wusste dass
schaut so leicht aus so wie beim
skifahren oder tennis spielen oder oder
bewegen aber man braucht wirklich
konzentration und bauherr kraft für die
meisten die heute zum ersten mal im
rollstuhl platz genommen haben war diese
erfahrung eine offensichtlich prägende
zeit bin ich aber ich muss gestehen bei
mir ganz sicher dass wir noch nicht
barrierefrei manchen bereichen sehr wohl
habe dienste haben die im rollstuhl
sitzen muss sich in jedem gebäude
da ist er ist jetzt komplett an sich
sehr gestreckt nichts anders und gibt
nicht doch das ist so schwierig ist über
und von veranstaltungen oder solcher
super kriegen es ist also wieder ein
schritt in die richtung barrierefreies
bundesheer gelungen
wie lange es wohl bis zum endgültigen
erreichen des großen ziels barrierefrei
noch dauern wird
vielleicht wenn mehr sportler der
inklusiv sind also ich glaube dass man
vielleicht über weil im sport gibt es
klare regeln
da kann man schnell sprachbarrieren
abbauen ich glaube dass es hier über den
sport vielleicht schneller zu einem
barriere abbau kommen könnte was meine
meinung
[Musik]